>>> THANKS AGAIN FOR BRINGING
OVER MY CALCULATOR.
SORRY, I FORGOT IT IN STUDY
HALL.
>> OH, IT'S MY PLEASURE.
WELL, MY MOTHER'S RUNNING LATE
SO I'LL JUST STAND BY THE
MAILBOX AND WAIT TO BE
RETRIEVED.
>> NO, JOSH -- YOU CAN WAIT
HERE.
COME SIT.
>> OVER HERE?
OKAY.
WOW.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY IT'S BEEN
REALLY GREAT BEING IN MATH CLASS
WITH YOU.
>> CASSIE, I WOULD HAVE TO
RETURN THE SENTIMENT.
>> I LOVE HOW YOU DO IMPRESSIONS
FROM THE CHARACTERS FROM
"FRASIER."
>> OH.
"THE NILES CAME QUICK."
I'M STILL WORKING AT MY RAW.
>> TOTALLY.
ANYWAY, I JUST WANTED TO SAY,
I'M GLAD YOUR MOM IS LATE.
>> GLAD, YOU SAY?
WOW.
>> YEAH.
REALLY GLAD.
>> TOOT, TOOT.
WOULD YOU EXCUSE ME FOR A
MOMENT?
BECAUSE I'M GETTING MY -- A CALL
FROM MY SCHWAB AGENT HERE.
JUST ONE SECOND.
HI.
IS MY B-F-F, JASON, THERE?
YES, I'LL HOLD.
>> HELLO, YOU HAVE JASON.
>> HI, JASON?
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BELIEVE WHAT
I'M ABOUT TO TELL YOU.
I AM SITTING EXCEEDINGLY CLOSE
TO THE HILLARY DUFF OF OUR
ALGEBRA CLASS.
>> TELL ME, WRAURTS YOUR BODY
LANGUAGE?
>> I AM SITTING ON NEXT TO HER
ON THE EDGE.
>> AND WHAT IS SHE DOING?
>> SHE'S LOOKING AT ME.
>> MY FRIEND, WE FIND OURSELVES
IN CHOPPY WATERS.
WE NEED TAKE HER BREATH AWAY.
SO PERHAPS WHISPER A SECRET IN
HER EAR, AND DO IT SENSUALLY.
>> YES.
PLEASE HOLD.
>> I ONCE GOT MONO FROM A
TROMBONE.
>> WOW, THANKS FOR TELLING ME
THAT.
I FEEL LIKE I KNOW YOU BETTER.
>> OKAY, THAT WENT SHOCKINGLY
WELL.
>> GOOD NEWS, OLD CHAP.
NOW TIME TO IMPRESS HER.
TELL HER A RECENT
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
>> RIGHTO.
CASSIE, YOU KNOW, MY -- MY
PARENTS SAID I WAS VERY
EMOTIONALLY MATURE WHEN WE PUT
DOWN MY TURTLE.
>> OH, WELL, AT LEAST HE DIDN'T
SUFFER.
>> WELL, HE ACTUALLY DID, THE
DOCTOR DIDN'T HIT HIM IN THE
RIGHT SPOT.
>> THAT'S INTENSE.
SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE REALLY
STRONG.
>> JASON, AGAINST ALL ODDS, I AM
CONTINUING TO CRUSH.
>> WITH MY ADVICE, I CAN'T FEIGN
SURPRISE.
BUT YOU NEED TO FIND OUT IF SHE
IS AVAILABLE.
>> YES, YES.
PLEASE HOLD.
CASSIE, ARE YOU CURRENTLY DATING
ANYONE?
>> NO, I'M DONE WITH JOCKS.
I LIKE QUIET GUYS.
OR, ACTUALLY, GIRLS TOO.
>> UNLESS MY BRAIN SHORT
CIRCUITED, WE HAVE A MODERN
WOMAN ON OUR HANDS.
>> GOOD.
THEN LET'S UP THE ROMANCE.
ACT LIKE YOU'RE IN A MOVIE AND
WIPE AN EYELASH FROM HER FACE.
>> OKAY, BRILLIANT.
STAND BY, PLEASE.
OKAY, I DID IT.
>> WELL, HOW DID IT GO?
>> I DIDN'T TELL HER THAT'S WHAT
I WAS DOING, SO I'M NOT SURE.
>> DANG, I KNEW THE EYELASH WAS
A TYPO.
>> CAN I PUT MY HEAD ON YOUR
SHOULDER?
>> SHOULDER.
>> CALL ATTENTION TO YOUR KNEE
SO SHE KNOW IT'S THERE.
NOW, IF SHE LIKED, SHE MAY TOUCH
IT WITH HER OWN.
>> OKAY, WE HAVE CONTACT.
THE KNEE.
WE ARE AFFIRMATIVE.
PATELAU ON PATELAU AND I CAN
FEEL MY PEN IN MY HEAD.
>> THIS IS OFFICIALLY ABOVE MY
PAY GRADE.
>> YOU HAVE TO STAY WITH ME.
THE STAKES ARE LIFE AND DEATH.
>> WELL, CHECK FOR SHOULDER
DEMEANOR.
STIFF OR LOOSE?
>> I'M CHECKING, REMAIN ON THE
LINE, PLEASE.
OH, DEAR GOD, SHE'S MET MY GAZE.
WE'RE LOOKING AT EACH OTHER,
WE'RE SHARING BREATH, WE'RE
BECOMING SOULMATES.
AND YET, I FEEL AFRAID.
NOT OF LOVE BUT OF LOSING YOU,
>> NAY, SAVOR THIS, MY GOOD MAN.
'TIS THE SPICE OF LIFE.
>> HEY, CAN -- CAN WE KISS NOW?
>> YOU HEARD THE WOMAN.
I'LL SEE YOU ON THE OTHER SIDE.
[ APPLAUSE ]